let's do another problem from the normal
distribution section of ck-12 dot orgs
AP statistics book and I'm using this
because it's open source it's actually
quite a good book the problems are I
think good practice for us so let's see
number three number two you could go to
their sidemen I think you can download
the book assume that the mean weight of
one year-old girls in the US is a
normally distributed or is normally
distributed with a mean of about nine
point five grams that's got to be
kilograms I have a ten month old son and
he weighs about 20 pounds which is about
nine kilograms not nine point to the
nine point five grams is nothing this
would be talking about like like mice or
something now this has got to be
kilograms but anyway it's about nine
point five kilograms with a standard
deviation of approximately 1.1 grams so
the mean is equal to nine point five
kilograms I'm assuming and the standard
deviation is equal to one point one
grams without using a calculator so
that's an interesting clue estimate the
percentage of one-year-old girls in the
US that meet the following condition so
when they say that without a calculator
estimate that's a big clue or a big
giveaway that we're supposed to use the
empirical rule empirical empirical rule
sometimes called the 6895 99.7 rule and
this is actually if you remember this is
the name of the rule you've essentially
remembered the rule what that tells us
if we have a normal distribution I'll do
a bit of a review here before we jump
into this problem if we have a normal
distribution let me draw a normal
distribution so it looks like that
that's my normal distribution I didn't
draw it perfectly but you have the idea
it should be symmetrical this is our
mean right there that's our mean if we
go one standard deviation above the mean
and one standard deviation below the
mean so this is one stance so this is
our mean plus one standard deviation
this is our mean minus one standard
deviation the probability of finding a
result if we're dealing with a perfect
normal distribution
that's between one standard deviation
below the mean
and once temptation above the mean that
would be this area and it would be you
could guess 68 percent 68 percent 68
percent chance you're going to get
something within one standard deviation
of the mean we their standard yishun
below or above or anywhere in between
now if we're talking bout two standard
deviations around the mean so if we go
down another standard deviation so we go
down another standard deviation in that
direction and another standard deviation
above the mean and we were to ask
ourselves what's the probability of
finding something within those two or
within that range then it's you could
guess it 95 percent and that includes
this middle area right here so it's a
the sixty-eight percent is a subset of
that ninety-five percent and I think you
know where this is going if we go three
standard deviations below the mean and
above the mean the empirical rule or the
68 95 99 point seven rule tells us that
there is a ninety-nine point seven
percent chance ninety-nine point seven
percent chance of finding a result in a
normal distribution that is within three
standard deviations of the mean so above
three standard deviations below the mean
and below three standard deviations
above the mean that's what the empirical
rule tells us now let's see if we can
apply it to this problem so they gave us
the mean and the standard deviation let
me draw that out let me draw my axes
first as best as I can
that's my axis let me draw my bell curve
let me draw the bell curve it's about as
good as a bell curve is you can expect a
freehand draw to do and the mean here is
nine point and this should be symmetric
this height should be the same as that
height there I think you get the idea
I'm not a computer nine point five is
the mean I won't write the units it's
all in kilograms one standard deviation
above the mean so one standard deviation
above the mean we should add one point
one to that because they told us a
standard deviation is one point one
that's going to be ten point six if we
go let me just draw a little dotted line
there one standard iation below the mean
one standard deviation below the mean
we're going to subtract one point one
from 9.5 and so that would be that would
be what eight point four point four if
we go two standard deviations above the
mean we would add another standard
deviation here right we went one
standard deviation two standard
deviations that would get us to eleven
point seven and if we were to go three
standard deviations we'd add one point
one again that would get us to twelve
point eight doing it on the other side
one standard deviation below the mean is
eight point four two standard deviations
below the mean subtract one point one
again would be seven point three and
then three standard deviations below the
mean if you're right there would be six
point two kilograms so that's our set up
for the problem so what's the
probability that we would find a
one-year-old girl in the US that has
that weighs less than eight point four
kilograms or maybe I should say whose
mass is less than eight point four
kilograms so if we look here the
probability of finding a baby or female
baby is one years old with a mass or
weight of less than eight point four
kilograms that's this area right here I
said mask because kilograms is actually
a unit of mass but most people use it as
weight as well so that's that area right
there so how can we figure out that area
under this normal distribution using the
empirical rule well we know we know what
this area is we know what this area
between minus one standard deviation and
plus one standard deviation is we know
that that is 68% and if that's 68% then
that means in the parts that aren't in
that middle region you have 32% because
the area under the entire normal
distribution is 100 or a hundred percent
or one depending on how you want to
think about it because you can't have
well you know all of the possibilities
combined there you know you can only add
up to one it you can't have it more than
a hundred percent there so if you add up
this leg and this leg so this Plus that
leg is going to be the remainder so 100
minus 68 that's 32 32% 32% is if you add
up this left leg and this right leg over
here and this is a perfect normal
they told us it's normally distributed
so it's going to be perfectly
symmetrical so this side and that side
add up to 32 but they're both
symmetrical meaning they have the exact
same area then this side right here do
it in pink this side right here I end up
looking more like purple would be 16%
and this side right here would be 16% so
your probability of getting a result
more than one standard deviation above
the mean so that's this right hand side
would be 16% or the probability of
having results less than one standard
deviation below the mean that's this
right here 16% so they want to know the
probability of having a baby or at
one-years-old less than eight point four
kilograms less than eight point four
kilograms is this area right here and
that's 16 percent so that's 16 percent
or Part A let's do Part B between seven
point three and eleven point seven
kilograms so between seven point three
that's right there that's two standard
deviations below the mean and eleven
point seven one two standard deviations
above the mean so they're essentially
asking us what's the probability of
getting result but within two standard
deviations of the mean right this was
the mean right here this is to stamp
duty two standard deviations below this
is two standard deviations above well
that's pretty straightforward the
empirical rule tells us between two
standard deviations you have a 95
percent chance of getting that result or
a 95 percent chance of getting a result
that is within two standard deviations
so the empirical rule just gives us that
answer and then finally Part C the
probability of having a one-year-old
u.s. baby girl more than twelve point
eight kilograms so twelve point eight
kilograms is three standard deviations
above the mean so we want to know the
probability of having more than three
standard of a result more than three
standard deviations above the mean so
that is this area this area way out
there that I drew in orange maybe I
should do it in a different color to
really contrast it so it's this long
tail out here this little small area so
what is that probability so let's turn
back to our empirical rule well we know
the probability we know this area we
know the area between minus three
standard deviations and plus three
standard deviations we know this I can
sis's the last problem I can color the
whole thing is we know this area right
here between minus 3 and plus 3 that is
99.7% the bulk of the results fall under
there I mean almost all of them so what
do we have left over for the two tails
remember there are two tails this is one
of them and then you have the results
that are less than three standard
deviations below the mean this tail
right there so that tells us that this
less than three standard deviations
below the mean and more than three
standard deviations above the mean
combined have to be the rest well the
rest there's only it's only 0.3% for the
rest or the rest and these two things
are symmetrical they're going to be
equal so this right here is has to be
half of this or 0.15 percent and this
right here is going to be 0.15 percent
so the probability of having a
one-year-old baby girl in the US that is
more than twelve point eight kilograms
if you assume a perfect normal
distribution is the area under this
curve the area that is more than three
standard deviations above the mean
and that is 0.15 percent point one five
percent anyway hope you found that
useful